más cambios en colombia el gobierno de
gustavo petro suspenderá los bombardeos
militares sobre campamentos guerrilleros
donde puedan haber menores de edad los
menores
reclutados forzosamente por
organizaciones ilegales son víctimas
son víctimas de esta violencia en la que
hemos vivido por tantas décadas
por lo tanto toda acción militar que se
desarrolle respecto de miembros de
organizaciones
y armadas ilegales
no pueden poner en peligro la vida de
estas víctimas la medida busca cambiar
el rumbo de la administración anterior
en noviembre de 2019 el entonces
ministro de defensa dimitió tras
coordinar una acción militar en la que
murieron menores entre los 12 y los 17
años y para finales del 2021 se denunció
la muerte de cuatro menores durante otra
operación el primer gobierno de
izquierda de colombia se propone
priorizar los derechos humanos y futuros
bombardeos estarán condicionados para
esa operación después pasan a realizados
si ya tienen un sentido
de acuerdo al
informe
quiere decir eso es que tenemos que
hacer una más alta votación para estar 5
es un primer paso del largo camino que
supone la restitución de derechos a los
jóvenes y a los llamados niños soldados
esclavos modernos de la guerra usados
sistemáticamente para aumentar el pie de
fuerza ilegal según el informe de la
comisión de la verdad el cual relató los
horrores de la guerra en colombia
alrededor de 16 mil 200 menores fueron
reclutados durante el conflicto armado
entre 1990 y 2017 y teniendo en cuenta
el subregistro las víctimas podrían
ascender a 30.000 en menos de un mes de
mandato petro ha dado vuelta a las
políticas bélicas tradicionales propuso
cambios en los acuerdos de extradición
para narcotraficantes ejecutó reformas
policiales y militares y se concentra en
retomar los diálogos de paz con la
guerrilla de la ln además de iniciar
procesos con otros grupos delictivos